décidément ces dernières années le
chanteur chris brown aurait plus fait
parler de lui dans la rubrique faits
divers que pour ses exploits musicaux
l'ex compagnon de rihanna accusé par
cette dernière de violence conjugale est
aujourd'hui au coeur d'une nouvelle
affaire qui fait grand bruit en
déplacement à paris le jeune homme de 29
ans est aujourd'hui accusé par une femme
de viol une accusation pour laquelle il
a fait une garde à vue dont il est sorti
hier sans charges contre lui pour le
moment
les faits se seraient déroulés dans la
nuit du 15 au 16 janvier dernier où
après une soirée dans un club près des
champs elysées
la jeune femme aurait suivi le chanteur
jusqu'à son hôtel c'est là que selon
elle elle aurait été violée par chris
brown son garde du corps et un ami du
chanteur par le biais de son avocat la
star dément énergiquement toute
application et à poster sur les réseaux
sociaux à ses 50 millions de followers
de message pour le moins explicite sept
morts suivi d'un commentaire je veux
être parfaitement clair c'est faux
jamais pour ma fille et ma famille c'est
irrespectueux et en contradiction avec
ma personnalité et mon éthique des
messages depuis supprimé des réseaux
certainement à la demande de son avocat
dans le passé il paraît que son est déjà
pris à rihanna oui je voulais dire ça
reste quand même un gros connard c'est
bien parce qu'on est dans le magnéto et
arnaud lafon
remercia tous heureusement que vous êtes
là doucement merci à l'est aujourd'hui
toute façon je vous lis et la transition
c'est ça on peut faire ce qu'on veut
comme au club med c'est le jour où ça
arrive c'est comme la couleur c'est vrai
que vous avez prononcé le mot d'avocats
c'est le mot le plus important c'est
quand on connaît les avocats américains
contre et ce sont des millions et des
millions parrot asteroid je veux te dire
mon gars les avocats américains fas
voilà mais certains même battu van
melsen ta mieux fait d'eux les avocats
américains moi j'ai eu à faire un avocat
américain sur une affaire je me tenir à
huy à marguerittes et on a fermé je suis
à faire un avocat programmes télé soit
quoi sur les programmes télé gratuite
aveugle vous pouvez explicité parce que
c'est vous dire la vérité un jour
j'étais aux états unis j'étais parti
trois jours à los angeles avant 80 et on
m'a volé une paire de burlington non ça
que vous étiez sérieux là sinon ça c'est
dans balances ton post